well lebanon has been plunged into
darkness after its two largest power
stations were shut down due to a
prolonged fuel shortage officials there
say the outage will last several days
it's the latest hardship for people in
lebanon where three-quarters of the
population are in poverty due to soaring
prices and record unemployment
financial crisis has kept lebanon's
economy in the red
and now fuel shortages have plunged it
into darkness
electricity used to be cut off for just
three hours then recently we only had
three hours of electricity now it's none
first the power went out at the daira
mar plant then the zarani plant went
offline the outages caused lebanon's
entire electrical grid to collapse
we're spending our time outside our
homes so our children can have fun the
situation is getting bad may god protect
us from what's next
many people have come to depend on
private generators that run on diesel
but that's in short supply too and it
like most goods is becoming pricey since
2019 lebanese currency has dropped 90
percent
this outage has added more weight to the
burden people must carry here
i live on the 11th floor i can't go up
or down sometimes i sleep in the car
what else can i do
the army has agreed to provide six
thousand kiloliters of gas oil securing
power in lebanon for just three days
you